well I never stick to one anyways that's
just not gonna happen I don't think and
it's funny when I work with like I
worked with the Cohen Brothers I kept
saying like and or or like there was
some tiny thing change and Ethan Cohen
walks up to me after he had told me a
couple times like you know this is the
line or whatever and I just kept
botching this one line and he came up to
me and he just put his hand on my
shoulder and he goes because he's very
quiet and he was just like Jonah you're
um
you're actually
um
you're killing me
I'm gonna die and it's just like in
moments like that and even with
Tarantino too he's such a brilliant
writer but not that I'm wasted in those
environments in those two movies it
maybe could have been any decent actor
in that role because they're such
they're so brilliant you're in their
painting whereas like in Wolf of Wall
Street or or Moneyball or the coolest
thing about Martin Scorsese ever is
unless you do your thing he he just
loves to see what you're gonna do right
he enjoys it